AUTOMATED VOICE: Hello.
This is a free call from
an inmate at Denver Sheriff's
Department County Jail.
ELISABETH EPPS: Hi, good
afternoon, how can I help you?
Everyone who we post bond for
is legally innocent.
SPEAKER:
I'm wondering if I qualify.
EPPS: The letters
come addressed to me.
"Dear Ms. Elisabeth."
They're often full
of really difficult stories.
"Three bonds preventing me
from release."
Total, 11,000 dollars.
I've been arrested...
Take your hands off of me!
...went to law school.
Of course I would be
directing a bail fund.
When I'm looking
at a jail roster
and I'm seeing how many
people we got out,
all I can really see is
how many people are still in.
SPEAKER 2: Is there any way
you guys can help me?
EPPS: I get overwhelmed
thinking about who's not
gonna be home for Christmas.
I saw Elisabeth paying
someone's bond.
"This is the money for this one,
this one, this one."
Let's start with Ms. Payne.
Liberation is not
a zero-sum game.
I get more free.
You get okay too.